nobody ODS at 50 like nobody reaches
their bottom as we say in 127 at 59 this
happens to like 19y olds no I think it
happens to everybody 59 so so when do
you realize that you're in a psych hold
like when oh as soon as once once I was
in ER I wasn't feeling messed up I
wasn't High anymore right so I think I
just thought I could talk my way out of
it go home and just kind of
recuperate and you know what I didn't
realize at the time that I really did
need serious help now I didn't go to
rehab because it was the height of covid
prevaccine but um the hospital
introduced me to two people that are
professional like recovery 12-step
people and they came over every day for
four months and Ted me every day and all
that but the py hold I'm I'm fascinated
three days so you're in the you're in
the ER well yes and then they when are
you told you can't go home when uh after
about an hour well when they first said
we're going to put you want a 5150 oh
they say that to you and because I've of
course done material in my ACT about
Kanye and Britney Spears I know exactly
what a 5150 is and then I started trying
to talk my way out of it and that's when
they pulled back the curtain and that's
where the cops were and then they just
process you like any other time you're
in the hospital and then do they walk
you upstair is there a are you in a lock
down well you're on you're getting an IV
of sailing right so you're already
Tethered to NIV so they just roll you in
the gurnie and they I actually did get
my own room which was good and so I was
just in a room for three nights and they
had this poor woman that would sit at
the foot of the bed and I honestly
didn't understand what was going on you
didn't and I would you didn't know
that's like a suicide watch my go oh my
gosh consua you should go I'm totally
just G to fall asleep I know I'm being
boring today and she'd be like oh miss
Griffin well like she wouldn't say
anything and I really didn't know that
she's the SU side watch Person you
didn't know that and I just cuz I I
thought that was for crazy people not me
you thought that she was there just but
you understood that you were in a 5150
hold right so I don't understand why I
thought I was being watched enough by
like whatever nurses just come by to
change the bag or whatever so I was like
oh well somebody's checking on me
constantly how would I ever escape like
was inconceivable to me that I would
Escape or that they think I would escape
and so I couldn't even imag it's not
even Escape I think they're watching to
see that you don't hurt yourself with
the needle that's going into your arm
but I thought oh and that's when I did
get up to walk in the hall one time and
realized that the door is locked from
the
outside and I was like click click oh
right so no I really wasn't taking it in
a real time I was processing how how do
they make a decision then that your 5150
is done are there people coming in and
interviewing you and seeing what your
mental state is I texted my cardiologist
who's the one that you know wisely said
you have to go to the hospital and I
said what do I what can I do to get out
of here and he said they have to keep
you 72 hours because of all the stuff
you took and everything and they also
asked you if you wrote a note and I said
yes and so by being honest about that
that's another sign that they go okay
she didn't just take all these that are
in her urine sample she admitted to
writing a note so they judge the
seriousness based on some questions is
it more serious to write a not yeah yeah
I I think they think that means you you
mean
business that you to a doctor I think as
they're looking at the criteria for what
would get somebody committed to a 5150
so in answer to her question what is the
so by law they have to hold you for 72
hours is there are they coming in and
are they testing you are they asking you
questions the day one I didn't see
anybody I just had an IV was saline and
they were just kind of busy getting to
other patients day two a psych I guess
it would be a psychiatrist a
psychiatrist well an MD came to the room
and she's the one that said um you know
CU I said I will do anything I said I
don't ever want to do this again I said
I didn't even mean to really attempt to
take my life this is all a nightmare
this is horrible what do I do so I will
say I when I reached my bottom as an
adct I knew it was my bottom I wasn't
trying to negotiate my way out of like
the help part and so that's what she
does is she asks you a bunch of
questions you don't do a psych Val she
just kind of talks to you and um you
know I guess they knew I wasn't using
anymore and she asked do you still want
to take your life and my guess is a lot
of people probably say yeah you know so
maybe the fact that I didn't and I said
no I don't and um you know kind of
helped get me sprung but that's when she
right away Saidi want you to meet people
that are Recovery Specialists and I like
the AA part because if you don't know
12st step there's no leader like it
can't be a cult there's not a leader
it's free you know so there's not like
so I was kind of glad that they were AA
was the issue the addiction or was the
issue the uh the trauma of everything
that you were going through I think I'm
an addict but I think it was the trauma
that led me to really not have a problem
till I was 59 years old that's pretty
unusual